well hello everyone
and thank you we've always wondered what
could happen if our crazy rabbits were
unleashed upon the world of mayo today
the dream is reality and to talk about
this unexpected encounter it is my great
honor to welcome a very special guest
someone I truly admire
[Applause]
miyamoto sod
thank you for coming you're sorry to
have you today so what what have you
brought
oh you well what did you bring this is a
right size paprika a one of the weapon
from this game Wow cool I'm sure you'll
love it
I brought one for you okay oh thank you
[Applause]
venison he can carry on a conversation
where a Corral no ghostery go to the
Chiodo these are a little bit different
from the weapons you see in Ghost Recon
how are you - oh yeah very different
weapons very different Wells this one is
I think very effective in the world of
my own rabbit
so should do well
and I'm so proud of you be soft
long-standing collaboration with
Nintendo you know from the ds2 the Wii
and more recently for the impressive
launch of the switch you know it has
always been we have always been inspired
by Nintendo and by all the great work
you have been able to do so it's now
home buddy
I know it's not UVs on you and IKEA
without a target of autonomous yes thank
you very much for all the work that
we've been able to do together over the
years with Ubisoft more ah they are
together do you wanna wear that awesome
isn't it
I mean Yves it's already been about 25
years since you and I first met there is
reto any gluten Vinny UVs an osso buco
Home Instead the video dr. Murad an
ocean I know video it was your study
semester and every year at e3 you're
kind enough to invite me to your booth
and we get to take lots of pictures and
videos and I've even recorded messages
for Ubisoft employees in the past as
well Dan Madinah Nabi I know Kai has
luminous on the Super Nintendo game y
matado can kinda dig much so over the
years I've always felt a deep heartfelt
passion that Ubisoft developers have for
Nintendo and it's characters disorder
Bohdan a Bhagwan Onizuka has selfish
their dive of this gonna go stay there
and combat it on but on the other hand
because we're both software developers
we've also looked at each others as kind
of rivals and and tried to see who could
make the best software because oh ma I
know it was not God I know Davidson on
you know more Atari or asleep but we
know ii know mining would have it's like
bad on desk Adamo and also you dive it's
no humor so good you guys so much but of
course I've known the rabbit's
characters for many years and I have
many rabbits figures decorating my desk
so I've always been a fan of the
characters and their humor dharak own
kinda hanashi wa ato de la vista Cadorna
u mo who gave monetary mississippi juco
suet on TV nice thoughts so since this
project first started i've been very
excited to see what kind of humour the
rabbits could bring to the mario world
they thought that i know there is a
Sonny a Toby then that is totally gonna
license so when I met David Ison who is
the
creative director of this game
when I when I met Davide son I had just
just one condition for this project the
cycle junkies of the game focus oh you
put up two home games are not there
Mario de mama discovered on an agenda
nor gave matsutake Tony isomers I said
whatever you do don't try to make a jump
game or a Mario platformer try to make a
Mario game that has never been made
before
and it's great and I can tell you it was
an exciting very exciting challenge for
all our teams and I think we've done
something you will load so thank you
very much for giving us a chance to to
perform on this game hi Antonio no for
Europa discrete okinawan Amida give no
katakana Sagara IDO you be a sci-fi
action game ooh Santos cute Erick
Eischen and they're constructed Tansen
of strategy game Tijuana note on topo
tempo no e game la de carreras and so of
course because the game is being made in
Europe it has a very unique flavor to it
and of course Ubisoft is very good at
making action games but this game in
particular has a great layer of strategy
and tactics to it but with a very good
pace
ya know it's going to be fresh actually
and so no let's welcome
zabi a you know the producer of the game
and he will show us the game
[Applause]
finally finally we can talk about this
project so we've been working on this
game for more than three years now and
to be at e3 today on this stage it's
just super exciting
so what is this game exactly
so Mario plus rabbit's kingdom battle is
a tactical adventure exclusive for the
Nintendo switch and let's check right
away some gameplay
[Applause]
[Music]
so the rabbits have been teleported into
the the Mushroom Kingdom
and it made the world completely
unstable and chaotic so Mario as a true
hero wants to save the day but this time
with some new friends
[Music]
and at first they don't really know each
others but in the end they will form
this dream team that will potentially
save the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
and as the game is a turn-based tactical
adventure game combat is a really big
part of the concept so you'll fight wave
after wave and rabbit that somehow turn
bad and what we see here is just the
very beginning of the game so it'll be
perfect to talk about the combat basics
so the two flags you see on the screen
here is to tell you this is a
battlefield zone so you'll switch from
exploration mode to battle mode the blue
zone is your zone of movement so you
move anywhere you want in that zone but
you can also use battlefield ingredients
such as covers for protection so rabbit
Luigi here using half cover or full
cover and we also have what we call team
jump so by jumping or your teammates you
can expand your zone of movement so here
rabbit teach using Mario she's able to
flank the enemy so you can also attack
the enemy behind that cover and expose
them by destroying that cover which is
really interesting in terms of strategy
because for next turns you'll be open
for attacks and that's but not least
techniques
so from defensive ones like rabbit peach
shield boost or offensive ones like
Mario's hero site he's able to attack
the enemy even if it's not his turn as
soon as the Emme moves
so this is a very core aspect of the
game itself so you mix and match attack
options movement abilities techniques
but we also have other ingredients such
as pipes rabbit pipes so it does give
you a a good move to flank the enemies
so here for example rabbit Luigi goes
into the pipe out of the pipe - the
enemy goes for Mario team jump land
behind the enemy in one single movement
sequence and then finish off the enemy
and what we see here is actually a
explosive cover so those have many type
of a super FX and this one was a push
effect so you can push heroes or enemies
out of the boundaries so again this is
just a glimpse into the basics of the
game and as you progress into the game
you have more tactic tools you'll be
able to do more combo setups you'll be
able to use different type of heroes
different type of weapons in order to
battle your way through the kingdom
[Music]
thank you and that's and that's just a
glimpse into the game itself but first
and foremost this is a project done with
passion with our hearts so it would not
exist otherwise so we just can't wait
for you guys to try the game at e3 this
week for those are not at e3 you'll see
online coverage videos and surprises so
have a great conference have a great
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]